What's number three then? So you've
given me two.
>> Yeah, we say say it with say it with
control. Say it with confidence. And
three is say it to connect. These are
how do you have how do you have these
difficult conversations with somebody?
How do you find ways to say what you
need to say in one of the most difficult
times? That gives a lot of people
anxiety if they know they have to have a
difficult conversation even in weeks
ahead, especially the day ahead. They're
just dreading it. Mhm. So, how do I say
something to connect?
>> Yeah. What you want to do is get really
curious about the other person, but not
just so much that there is a framework
that I'm I can even give you. So, we can
go a step further.
There is a frame and I call them
conversational frames. When to connect
with somebody, it is a fancy word. I
think connection can be overused at
times. just means I say something that
you can understand and you acknowledge
me. That's all we're looking for.
Doesn't mean that everything's happy.
Doesn't mean that's a hallmark car. Like
I can connect with you and still be
upset at you. My dad would used to tell
me if I came if I disagree with
something, he'd say, he would go, "You
don't have to like it. You just need to
understand it."
>> I mean, that that right there was a
great example of allowing me to connect
with him and giving me the the space to
disagree. If you were to begin your
sentence with, "I'm not asking to change
your mind." Or, "I don't need to change
your mind." It's almost like a relief
before you say the rest of what you need
to say. Now, you're not in that
combative fight or flight of do I have
to defend myself at any time. So,
connection is this way of setting up
conversations that is going to get you
more of what you want. We talked about
the frame. Here's how to do it. And this
is the most effective tool that you can
use for a difficult conversation. Number
one, you're going to begin with telling
them what you want to talk about. Number
two, you tell them, and this is the most
important, how you want to end the
conversation, what you want to walk away
from. And three, you get their buy in
into that conversational frame. This is
what it sounds like. Let's say this is I
need to come to you and talk about
something serious.
So, first I'm going to say, well, we
need to talk about Stephen. I'd like to
talk with you about some comments you
made at last Thursday's meeting. Two,
I'm going to tell them how I want to
walk away. It sounds like and I want to
walk away from that conversation with
the understanding that's not going to
happen again. Three, I'm going to get
their buy in. I'm going to say, "That
sound good." You're going to say, "Yeah,
now you know exactly where we're going.
You know exactly what we're going to
talk about. You know when that
conversation's going to end and how it's
going to end." And now I have your buy
in. And it's like almost an invisible
contract when somebody goes, "Yeah,
that's good. We can talk about that."
They don't want to leave it. They don't
want to break their words. So they they
know that they're going to be stuck in
it.
And then is there anything I need to be
aware of when I have that difficult
conversation with them so that I don't
so that I'm successful in getting to
that outcome? Number one would be set
the goal of knowing where it's going to
end. That that is the hardest probably
the biggest downfall of the difficult
conversation. People expect them to go
how they had it in their head. They want
the conversation to happen just like
they had it while they were brushing
their teeth that morning or driving on
the way in to work. They're like, "Okay,
I'm going to say this." And then they're
going to say this, and you expect
everything to go just how you had it in
your head. But as soon as they say that
one thing you weren't expecting,
all of a sudden, they disagree with you,
and you go, "Wait, that's not how it's
supposed to be. They were They're
supposed to say this. They were supposed
to say, "I'm right. They're supposed to
say they're wrong. I mean, uh, how's
this going to go?" And then it begins to
falter like that.
>> Cuz when we go into those sort of
difficult conversations, whether it's
with a colleague or our spouse or
whoever it might be, much of the
objective, I think, for some of us is to
is to win the conversation. Yeah.
>> In whatever definition of winning one
might have, is endeavoring to win a
conversation a good idea?
>> I teach that you never want to win an
argument. And this is why when you look
to win an argument, you will often lose
the relationship. Like if you set out to
only
prove people wrong, you might win the
point, but you will lose the person. You
know, being right doesn't keep you
company. Let's put it that way. When I
look at his arguments, there's only
something to win.
All I've won is really the first step to
to apologize typically when you set out
to win it. Because most arguments aren't
really won. It's just they're won by
forfeit. Somebody goes, I I'm over this.
Or you said it something that was really
hurtful that makes them say, I I don't
want to uh we're done. I don't want to
talk about this. An argument eventually
burns out. That's what happens. But when
you set out to win, you will lose the
relationship. Like if you you and I are
in an argument and I say something
that's really hurtful and then you
leave, you hang up the phone. What have
I won?
>> Yeah. I mean, what I I've I've won
awkward silence now when we pass each
other in the hall. I've I've won that
awkward feeling. Now I have to pick up
the phone and apologize. I still have to
find a way to probably work with you or
live with you. What have you proven?
When is ever you
go onto social media and disparage
somebody's political belief? Ever change
their mind? Ever?
>> There's been so many arguments I've had
with like my girlfriend where I have
quote unquote won and I felt like
>> Yeah, you will.
>> Cuz I cuz she like she might come to me
and say, "Do you know what? I understand
your point and I'm I'm sorry." And
there's part of me that just feels like
And I I it's it's because I
thought that's the outcome I was looking
for, but actually the outcome I was look
looking for was resolution. And I
actually love this person so much that
a concession was not like was actually
not I it's not what I wanted. I actually
wanted to be happy with them.
>> Yeah. It's hard to, you know, I was
thinking of so many some recent examples
where my girlfriend came to me and
apologized for something where we were
like disagreeing about it and I just
felt like that she apologized. It's
hard to explain.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, no, that's not
an uncommon experience. Whenever you
felt like you had to always be right,
that's what we really want. We want the
last word. When you have the last word,
you are typically first up to apologize.
That's all you've that's all you've
bought yourself. That's the That's your
prize. Congrats. And when that happens,
you find a way of going, "That's not
really what I I wanted. Why did I say
that? That was just that was just
hubris. That was just me. I just had a
feeling of being right." And sometimes
we have that feeling of when especially
in terms of people that are in charge of
other people. Um, we expect others to do
what we say. When you're in work mode
and you say, "I need this done," people
get it done. You set the tone. This is
how we want to do it. And sometimes we
translate that into our own romantic
relationships.
>> Oh, no. I said it needs to be this way.
So, you know what you to do? You need to
do it this way.
>> And it's a different shift when you're
doing something that's romantic versus
something that is
>> you have to be captain of the the ship.
And so, whenever you're in those
difficult conversations, you only seem
something to win. You're going to have
our pro problem. What I teach is instead
of seeing arguments as something to win,
you see them as something to unravel.
Meaning what we want to do is pull my
way and then you pull it your way and it
just makes it worse. Makes it worse. We
have to give up. And it's not until that
next conversation that we actually try
and care of what happened. I will often
tell someone, "Help me find the knot.
Help me find the knot." And what I'm
doing is encouraging them to say, I'm
not saying, "What's wrong with you?" I'm
not saying, "Can can you be any more
stupid?" I'm saying, "Help me find the
knot." It's a way of detaching the
issue, detaching the problem, saying
this is something for us both to look
at, help unravel, where's the what am I
missing? That phrase right there is
very, very effective. If you can just
ask them the question, what am I
missing? They will always tell you, but
most likely it's not something that
you're focused on. You're only focused
on what you're saying. You're not
focused on what they're hearing. Big big
difference.
>> I have um two glasses on the floor here.
>> Yeah. Um,
try not to spill it.
>> Nice.
>> Since I've been a waiter,
>> um, so I have these two glasses of water
in front of me. What is I know there's
an analogy you have for having a good
effective conversation that can be
demonstrated with these two glasses of
water.
>> Yeah. So let's say that this glass right
here is all of my thoughts and knowledge
and your glass is all of your thoughts
and knowledge and not just what you
think now. These are things that you've
known throughout your entire life. So if
I were to tell you something
about I want to get your thoughts maybe
a political opinion or something that's
a religious belief. I'm talking like
deeply held beliefs that you grew up
with. That's what's in that cup right
there. When we go into a conversation
with someone,
often what we find is, especially if
it's like a stranger, that what I say in
our first conversation should convince
you automatically that if I were to take
all of my knowledge right here and I
pour it in, there should be no problem.
But what but what happens when I start
to pour into here?
It overflows. Meaning, you have no room.
you have no room for what I want to
share whatsoever. It's going to just
it's overflow. Instead, what you have to
find are ways to ask questions and get
really curious. Meaning, instead of me
pushing my point, instead of saying why
do you believe that? Beginning your
question with why, I start to get really
curious about how did you come to
believe that? Where did you learn that?
When did this happen? ways that I get to
ask questions every day like I do as a
trial attorney to find ways of getting
to the issue of what's that deeply held
belief, where does it come from? Because
only then, let's go ahead and pour yours
into mine.
There you go. Perfect. And so it's only
then until you have space that I'm
asking questions whenever I ask
questions and you start to answer just a
little bit more and then you answer just
a little bit more to where you actually
have space to care at all to what I'm
going to tell you. Like you can't fill
I can't fill a glass that's already full
with new thoughts. It's not going to
happen. It's not until I can get you to
pour it all out till you'll ever be
receptive and have room for what I want
to share with you. So, that's the key in
difficult conversations that you have to
find ways to get really curious about
who's the person behind the words
because the person you see isn't the
person you're talking to. I might be
talking to Stephen right now, but there
are things that happen in your life that
you believe that happened long before I
ever talked to you. And we have this
hubris about us that we think that just
because I told you you should believe
something right at this moment, you're
going to automatically change your mind.
Minds don't get changed in one
conversation. They happen over a year of
a hundred conversations, a thousand
conversations before anybody will ever
be receptive to what you have to say.
>> So what's like a real world example of
this idea that you might not be talking
to Stephen, you might be talking to
something he's dealing with.
>> Yeah. So, let's put it in terms of I've
had a a client before. Uh, this is not a
Let me rephrase that. I had a deposition
before where I was talking to a witness
and he was a huge mountain of a man. His
name was Bobby L Prey. I'm talking he
was huge. His hands, I mean, he just
looked I looked like I was physically
deficient in every way next to this guy.
And it didn't matter what I asked him,
Stephen, he got mad at me. I mean, I was
asking him basic things like, "Where
were you where were you born?" Okay. And
where'd you where'd you go next? And
what happened next? And every time he
would just get angrier and angrier. And
eventually I had to ask him. I said, "Do
you need a break?" And he said, "No, but
I got something to say." And I thought I
thought he was about to just flip the
the table on me. He was just so furious.
And I asked him, well, once he even told
me, he said, "You you can cut all this
buddy buddy stuff." except he didn't say
stuff. And he said, "You you lawyers,
you attorneys, you're the worst thing to
happen in this government. You're the
worst thing to happen. So you can go on
and ask your stupid questions. I don't
trust you as far as I can throw you."
Well, instead of taking that bait, which
most people wanted to do, I asked him a
question. I said,
"What am I missing? What's what are you
struggling with right now in your in
your life? What's been your biggest
struggle?" And they have to ask my they
have to answer questions in a
deposition. And what I learned was that
he big Bobby L Prey, this huge guy had
just put his mother in a nursing home
and he was the only one to take care of
her. His dad had died. His brother was
off. And he had been getting letters for
months
about his mom and her home from lawyers
about foreclosing, making demands, debt
collection, all these things that he
just didn't understand. And so, right
then in that moment, I represented
everything he knew about the law and
lawyers and everything else. And so, the
person I saw was an aggressive mad
witness. The person I was talking to was
a worried son and and we got to talk
that out and I helped him and it was a
it ended it ended wonderful. We ended
actually hugging. But every day you had
these micro moments of the person you
see is not the person you're talking to.
The the waitress that looks like she's
being rude and dismissive is actually
worried because she should have gotten
off two hours ago and her mom is still
keeping her kids. or you have somebody
who even in the workplace who seem like
they're a little bit short on their
their phone call with you,
somebody who looks like they're
aggravated. Actually, their day began
because, you know, he and his wife are
going through a divorce and they stayed
up all night arguing. Everybody has a
struggle that you can't see. They're
having a conversation in their head that
you were not invited to. And so when you
have the patience to try and understand
the person behind the words, it's going
to go a whole lot better for you and
they'll feel that when you just want to
accept them for what they look like,
it's it's always different. Like when I
if I were to tell you you were wrong
about something
for me to change your mind, like right
now, I most likely am not saying that
Steven's wrong. I'm saying your parents
are wrong. I'm saying a grandparents
wrong. something you grew up your whole
life was wrong. That camp you went to
growing up was all wrong. There's pieces
and identities that have all combined
into what you believe now. And we have
this horrible habit of thinking for some
reason that if I say it to you right in
this moment, it's all going to change
and you're going to just immediately
conform to what I want you to be.
>> Being triggered is a hallmark of that,
isn't it? like being when we say, "Oh
dear, god, they're like easily
triggered." It's really you're
scratching at an open wound that might
have been there many years ago. I I was
reflecting as you were speaking about a
particular friend that I have who I
remember a conversation with him in the
middle of the pandemic where he like
turned to me and said, um,
it's people that are young and healthy
that are ending up in the hospital beds.
And I remember saying to him, I was
like, I was living in his house. I was
like, "No, I don't think that I think
the the NHS website says it's people
that are like out of shape and slightly
older that are ending up in hospital
beds." And he like was like really
really triggered by that.
>> And I remember he's like a good friend
of mine. So we had a conversation about
it and we dug and dug and dug cuz we're
like really good friends like why why is
it that all of us as like boys we know
in like the group chat when we're
bantering all we've got to do is say
like now you're wrong.
>> Wait, one
>> one thing and it's like red mist.
>> Yeah. and we had like a really open
conversation about it over really over
the last like year and a half. And he
said, "Um,
when I was younger, all of the teachers
thought I was stupid. And also, I then
got bullied on the playground because
people thought I was stupid. And then I
found text messages from my grandmother
to my mom where they said I was stupid.
And then I found on my report card,
they'd basically written me off. So 30
years later when we're having a
conversation just a trivial conversation
about the pandemic when I go no I don't
think that's right and I like pull up
the website and stuff
>> and he gets like sees the red mist as me
and him call it now it all stems back 30
years to this experience of on the
playground so
>> like you said it could be proving
proving someone wrong but in that case
it's actually like proving the bullies
right. It's proving all the people that
hurt him right and it's showing up 30
years later as this red mist. The story
ends with him going to a therapist and
speaking about it and he's resolved it
now to the extent to which he can where
now when he feels that feeling he's able
to point it he knows what it is and so
it doesn't make the decision
>> right knowing your trigger is one of the
biggest ways to defend against that to
know your trigger and it's funny how
just like your friend is telling you so
many things in everybody's life goes
back to the playground
>> like we can remember that thing that
that one kid said like right now we can
probably remember it. Somebody said in
high school
>> came straight to mind
>> and and it's it's been years years but
you remember it
>> and it lives with you for that long um
of just simply what they had said in
that moment that you've created that
identity that's that's a trigger
>> and if you tend to hit somebody with a
trigger it's different like you can
always it's very telling in the
courtroom when somebody takes a level
one conversation and they ratchet it up
to a level And it's very
disproportionate
and it tells you that there's a
conversation happening in their head
that you weren't invited to. It tells
you that something else is is going on.
And when you have the patience and the
discipline to find that person rather
than just
fighting the surface, it's you will
always have a deeper connection with
that other person.
If you're dealing with someone in your
romantic relationship, at work, whatever
that is easily triggered in that regard,
what advice would you give to the person
dealing with that person who is like
continually easily triggered? They see
the red mist all the time. It's almost
impossible to talk to them because they
immediately just flip to 10.
>> Yeah.
>> They avoid the difficult conversation.
you feel now that you can't even have
that conversation with them because
they're immediately gonna gaslight you
or they're just going to go straight to
10 and they're gonna be flooded,
>> right?
>> You know that phrase that I've heard
before about like when the brain gets
flooded like they just get overwhelmed
in there.
>> Yes.
>> What do you do with that kind of person?
You just curious or
>> Well, it's I don't want to just say
curious because I don't I think that
doesn't do it justice. One would be you
have to delay what you what they said
from when you respond. You have to add a
lot of distance there because if you
continue to engage and go why why can't
you talk about this? What's wrong with
you? That will only spiral it more. What
they're going to hear is something is
wrong with me. Something I am feeling is
bad. When in that moment their body is
fighting. Their body is going I feel
threatened. I feel anxious. I got to get
out of here. and it's happening in micro
minutes that you there's nothing you're
going to be able to say that's going to
help that trigger aside from you
allowing them the space to have it. So
that means you're going to find ways to
approach conversations
with that in mind. So one would be
adding distance and not addressing it in
that current conversation because
they're triggered. You don't want to do
that. You want to find it in the second
conversation. So in the first one, you
can easily end it with, "Hey, we can
drop it. Not a problem. We can talk
about it later." Because problems
happen, Stephen, when you try and push
people into having conversations on your
timeline. In other words, when they're
not ready. Ever had somebody come up to
you and go, "Hey, I need to talk to you
right now." And and you're like, "You
want to talk?" Like, that's the last
thing. You're you're trying to control
my time. This is not what I want to talk
about right now, and I'm not ready for
this conversation. And that that causes
a big problem when somebody's trying to
push their timeline on you. You um we
can talk about ways to to deal with
that, but it is that's what happens. And
when you do it with somebody going,
"What's wrong with you? Let's talk why
can't you talk about this right now?"
You're just pushing them into a corner
and you're making them harder. I mean,
you just they become hardened. They'll
totally shut off from you. Then they're
gone. Then they won't come back for
several days most likely. So when you
start to push on them, things are go
wrong. So that's when somebody's feeling
triggered. That second conversation,
that next conversation is the I like
let's put a frame on it. I like to talk
about what we began talking on on last
Monday and I I'm not trying to solve
anything. I just want to understand
where you're coming from so that I can
do better. Can we do that? like right
there. That's gonna be a much better way
to set up and frame that difficult
conversation rather than going, "Hey, so
um I question for you. Uh what's up with
you?" Because something's something's
off. All right? Like that's the way that
it's going to you're going to trigger
them again. If you enjoyed that clip and
want to see the rest of the
conversation, you can click right here.
Or if you want to see the latest episode
of the Jefferson Fischer podcast, click
right here and I'll meet you